which led to the death of one policeman
all of the hostages
and five of the eight kidnappers as a
consequence of this tragedy the west
german government created gsg-9
so in the future if similar situations
arose they could be handled
appropriately by the right people many
german politicians opposed its formation
fearing gsg-9 would renew past memories
of the nazi party's ss force
the decision was made to form the unit
from police forces as opposed to the
military
unlike the equivalent forces in other
countries on the grounds that the german
federal law
expressively forbids the use of military
forces against the civilian population
the unit was officially established on
the 26th of december 1972
as part of germany's federal police
agency gsg-9 is deployed in cases of
hostage taking
kidnapping terrorism and extortion the
group may also be used to secure
locations
neutralize targets track time fugitives
and sometimes conduct sniper operations
at the swat world challenge in 2005 gsg9
won eight of the eight events
beating 17 other teams and defending its
championship the following year
after the reactivation of team rainbow
in 2015 four gsg nine commandos were
recruited to bring their skills and
expertise to assist in the fight against
terrorism on a global scale these
commandos were called blitz
iq jaeger and bandit
[Music]
foreign
elias cotes codenamed blitz is an
attacking operator in team rainbow
blitz is a graduate of hermann bust
gymnasium an elite academy
specialised in science and language
studies he excels at both an academic
and athletic level with an excellent
grasp of expression
sound and word meanings he's able to
pick up new dialects quickly and speaks
a number of different languages
once he left secondary school he
enlisted with chanel crafter
an airborne division of the german army
this division leads
three combat brigades and special forces
troops all of which are fully immobile
not long after blitz transitioned from
being a chanel crafted soldier in kosovo
to a member of gsg9 it's his tactical
experience that secured him as a solid
rambo elite
this combined with his academic
background and well-natured personality
make him a highly sought-after team
member
[Applause]
although he's seen his fair share of
combat his temperament remains cheerful
and friendly
blitz uses humor to defuse stressful
situations and is appreciated by his
teammates
and holds more value than he's given
credit for it's not that he doesn't take
his job seriously
on a number of occasions he's the first
to rush a barricade and is often placed
with team safety over his own
he prefers not to think of himself as
heroic but he believes it's more of a
quirk of his personality
while physical performance is considered
a vital part of a rainbow operative's
job
blitz stands out above the rest as an
exceptional beast
with all of his laughs and quick wit
blitz takes his role very seriously
his teammate's well-being is of utmost
concern and insists they all have a role
to play
and have a responsibility to look after
one another
unlike other explosive entry methods
blitz prefers the use of flashbang
grenades
disorientating enemies and limiting
collateral damage
the g52 tactical shield allows blitz to
quickly advance
and remain protected from frontal
attacks as he moves to aid teammates or
hostages
inspired by ballistic shields fashioned
with strobe lights the g52 tactical
shield takes his technology one step
further
by replacing the high intensity light
source with three rows of eight
flashbang grenades
the g52 allows for a bold and calculated
entry where the aim is to immobilize
rather than kill potential targets
[Music]
monica weiss codenamed iq is an
attacking operator in team rainbow
iq's mother is a renowned mathematician
and her father
an inventor a family of academics
iq and his siblings were encouraged to
meet high standards in math
science and music which led to a number
of awards throughout their school years
they were also encouraged to spread
their imaginations far beyond their own
intellectual intelligence
a gifted student iq undertook her first
internship with a local tech company
at the age of 16. following this she was
invited to mit
where she concentrated on electrical
engineering and achieved merit for her
research in microelectronics
later iq joined caltech in california
for graduate research
and experimental electrical engineering
after completing her studies she
traveled around the world for a year
eventually returning to germany to work
in the military technology research
field
before joining the german federal police
as an officer
the physical and mental demands of the
job appealed to her and she quickly
moved through the ranks
after two years working as a federal
officer she was approached and recruited
by gsg9
iq is active physically as she is
intellectually when she does manage to
pull herself away from rock climbing and
countless other athletic and
intellectual pursuits
she writes science fiction iq is a
rather isolated individual who struggles
to have any close friends
others often struggle to comprehend and
keep up with the way that she thinks
which can lead to a feeling
misunderstood by the world around her
it's clear that family is very important
to her as they are the only ones that
really truly understand her
however coming from a family of typical
overachievers she jokes that even she
gets worn out at family gatherings
socializing isn't something that comes
naturally to her and outside of the
usual research and training exercises
she doesn't spend a lot of time reaching
out to other operators
iq is highly sought after by a number of
companies and universities from around
the world
but instead she chose the law
enforcement she saw it as an opportunity
to work with state-of-the-art equipment
and express her love for her country at
the same time academic or university
research can be rewarding but it's
highly focused and structured
leaving less room for the wildly
creative approach that iq naturally
possesses
field reports mention that iq can become
obsessive when tackling challenges
which can lead to prolonged bouts of
insomnia this is due to her being unable
to switch off at the end of the day when
she feels that the task at hand hasn't
been completed
the growing presence of complex
electronics on battlefields has created
a pressing need for more advanced types
of portable ground-based sensors
inspired by forward-looking infrared
technology the red mark
iii spectre displays any active
electronic components in the immediate
vicinity of the user
from ieds to various types of
specialized military gear
iq designed the prototype for the red
mark 1 while a phd candidate at caltech
she maintained a firm hand in monitoring
the successive models of the device
as dictated in a licensing agreement
with the manufacturer
they said it could not be done
they said it was designed for tanks
they said i could not make it smaller
and more accurate
they were wrong
mario striker codenamed jaeger is a
defending operator in team rainbow
raised by his uncle a mechanic in the
german federal police aviation group
jaeger has been around engines since a
young age
while he demonstrated skill in
mechanical repair it didn't challenge or
hold his interest for long
because of his fondness for complex
machinery his uncle encouraged him to
study aeronautical engineering at
university
unfortunately the strict academic
structure proved daunting to him
and didn't fit well for his personality
while jaeger's grades were acceptable
he had a tendency towards clanish antics
which often got him into trouble with
his professors
following on from his hobby and passion
for flying he spent a considerable
amount of time around a number of pilots
and aircrafts
private corporations sought him out that
jaeger had other plans
and joined the federal police aviation
group because it offered him unique
challenges
and the opportunity to fly and serve his
country
almost immediately upon joining jaeger
began designing defensive weapon systems
including a ground-based active defense
system prototype
it was this prototype that caught the
attention of gsg9
and rainbow jaeger has a creative
curiosity
that is reflected in both his operations
and his daily life
he is a fondness for learning and often
talks about the latest documentaries
he's been watching
with a preference for robotics and
artificial intelligence as he's often
the topics he seeks out most
however he seems to enjoy almost
anything for example these may include
anything from nasa sending a probe to
the sun
to new discoveries about the
tyrannosaurus rex
jaeger shows a deep passion for his team
and can often be seen checking up on
people to see if they're doing okay
he enjoys sharing information so that he
can make connections
not just his connection with individuals
but a web of connections among everyone
his own upbringing wasn't particularly
lively or warm and the small family
meant that he had very little company
his own age
his uncle was a meticulous man who was
often closed off and had very little
sense of humor
nevertheless jaeger appreciates his
uncle and all that he has taught him
going as far to say that his uncle made
him a better person
but this is also likely the reason why
jaeger is so eager to create connections
with the team
he sees them as family and is intensely
protective of them
both during field operations and
downtime
jaeger has explored the importance of
defensive strategies alongside
breaching techniques throughout history
as well as the evolution of tech
and the historical analysis of strategy
and historical documentaries
with this in mind he makes use of the
active defense system gadget
known as the ads mark iv magpie
using the advanced cameras to identify
and target explosives to be disabled
before they reach their intended
[Music]
destination
i used to be undercover
i did time
i had to deal drugs
i even had to kill
and i was so good at it that
it got me a promotion
dominic brunsmeier codenamed bandit is a
defending operator in team rainbow
bandit and his twin brother were raised
in a working-class district near the
berlin wall
their father worked in the police force
and strongly encouraged them to pursue
the same career
which bandit did during his time working
with the federal police he out rivaled
his peers in crisis situations
and later he transferred to the aviation
group so he could obtain his helicopter
license
his experience and adaptability with
border surveillance gave him an edge
over
other offices and he was eventually
flagged for undercover operations
he was embedded as an undercover agent
in the terrorist organization
red army faction and later in the
hanover chapter of the hells angels
in both operations banned its
contribution was critical in seeing key
members arrested and providing valuable
information
while undercover banned at home skills
and guerrilla tactics and improvised
explosive devices
he developed prototypes of his
electrified barricade and deployable
shield
he grew up in the shadow of the berlin
wall and would often hear the boom of
landmines being triggered
as a twin he and his brother would prank
patrol guards
bandit is very close to his brother and
enjoys being an uncle to his brother's
kids
years of working undercover with the
dangerous biker gangs and militants
has had bandit learned to be
consistently on his toes
any slip up no matter how minor could
have had his cover blown
and had him killed so to say he's clever
and adaptive
is a serious understatement he had to be
creative and strategic to stay alive
yet he has maintained a healthy sense of
humor
bandit would describe the challenge of
remembering the real you when immersed
in an undercover operation
the question who are you would creep
into his sleep and if he did to form an
answer he knew he was as good as dead
even considering the question was
dangerous so he would push it away
rumors have circulated about what bandit
had to do to ensure that his cover
wasn't blown
if asked he'll just smile and say
they're only half true
it's critical that bandit doesn't close
himself off training scenarios alongside
operators such as castle
twitch or blitz could help these
operators have calming attributes
that may temper bandits in the demons
[Music]
the ced-1 is the result of bandit's
resourceful nature
first created when he was cornered in an
abandoned order shop outside of
frankfurt
using what was available to him bandit
fashioned a crude electrical device
and was able to secure his defenses by
electrifying a magnetic door
and shocking those assailants as they
attempted to breach the stronghold
this device though relatively low tech
has followed bandit from gst9 to team
rainbow due to its consistent and
effective performance in the field
any german viewers out there i apologize
i've never attempted to say a german
word in my life
so this video i've likely butchered
quite a number of them i have enough
trouble with my own language
guaranteed this will happen as i get
through the other operator teams too
this one took a little while to get out
as i've been distracted with other games
but i usually
have about half a dozen scripts on the
go so i always get there eventually
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
you